that about in a rather circuitous way
one of my favorite offers his son in
Winchester who wrote a book called
Krakatoa and then I started reading
every book that he wrote and every book
that he recommended and one of them was
called cascades fault which I read a few
weeks before I was headed up to a
conference in Seattle and I changed my
hotel because of it yeah exactly
it didn't want to be on the wrong side
of Highway five education saves life and
in the book the Seeley's work was
mentioned and I was stunned by quite a
few things in tsunami modeling and and
where it's gone and the real challenge
that they have to about these alerts
because when the Cascadia earthquake
happens next it is going to be amazingly
devastating and this is something that
we need to even worry about down here in
California so this dude thanks for the
introduction and thank you for inviting
to the excellent talks I was really
impressed you know with the breadth and
depth of the other things so what they
were presented what guess hell I'll
shift a little bit gears here we back to
earth first of all mostly the and just
to to introduce what to really to
introduce the problem you know what what
we had we do we have to deal with to do
the tsunami forecast and warning and the
reason we do the forecast do I am
involved in the forecast and warning I
work for the for the NOAA National
Oceanic Atmospheric Administration
that's that's the that's the science
agency but they have operational can't
actually big components it biggest
component of NOAA and part of it is
weather of course forecast weather
service and but the Weather Service also
do tsunami warning so tsunami warning is
done by this operational part of NOAA
and it's in
warning centers - warning centers do
operational forecast and warning one is
in the last kind one in is in Hawaii
which is also international tsunami
warning center so they provides 24/7
tsunami warning capabilities I work for
the research part of NOAA which is a
smaller part of NOAA obviously you know
the research usually is a small plant
and and we provide science big you know
sound science support for this for this
warning operation so we're developing
tools mostly for the forecast so that's
that's what my connection with with
tsunami is and I'm still consider myself
a scientist but there it's a noise is a
this agency but it's a science agency
it's a very mission oriented agency so
what I want to do in this talk is just
you know introduce the problem first of
all you know why do we care about
tsunamis you know how do we do this you
know why do we need to Nami warning how
do we do to Nami warning and what are
the challenges that we still face as
sort of the the bulk they be the outline
of the so so what's what's the problem
how big is the problem you know you
probably know about tsunamis from just
you know one maybe two maybe three
events that you hear and they in the
headlines but they actually happening
all the time it's just and and now with
Internet day they're becoming more more
known but but it's still it's since you
you may have heard about the the Indian
Ocean tsunami the Japan tsunami but
since the Indian Ocean tsunami which
happened in 2004 there were 50 50
tsunamis happened over that some
somewhere over the world and most of the
impact of course was from this - tsunami
but but the in the 15 years almost 15
years that that his gone since the know
2004 which was really watershed event in
terms of a tsunami science and tsunami
warning and forecast there was almost
quite a million people died from
tsunamis mostly from from these two
events
250 billion dollars in damage so it's
it's pretty pretty pricey hazard that's
four that's worldwide and again mostly
most of these so the people killed
actually is in this in the Indian Ocean
from this from the events that's stories
right here but most damage is actually
most most manic monetary damages from
the event in Japan which is all still
you know sixteen thousand people died
there but nothing compared to me to the
Indian Ocean event and there haven't
been any you know major tsunamis in the
coast of us actually but you asked you
spent over 100 million dollars on this
and this on mitigations of all these
events all those 50 events yes so to me
this is this is this sort of the number
that that gets my attention because we
with the hundred million dollars spent
for event that hasn't even happened yet
so that if it if it's going to happen at
the you know that the the code near the
coastline of us is going to be a major
impact and that's why we we do we try to
minimize to mitigate the damage and the
hazard right
well actually that's so the the the us
actually spent a billion dollars for the
whole for all the events there was the
small event the event there were
actually events in the u.s. it was there
was in 2009 there was tsunami in Samoa
and Samoa is US territory and there were
people killed there so that's that's the
major u.s. cost impact of tsunamis so
the tsunami science and is it is well
it's it's it started like beckon in
1930s in Japan really and the focus of
that is to forecast tsunami from the
very beginning it was how can we say
something about the potential tsunami
that's happening and the way it was done
you know in Japan and 1930s it was the
just based on the on really the power of
the earthquakes so you get some estimate
of the earthquake magnitude and that's a
proxy for the tsunami power very very
crude estimate by the way but from the
very beginning you know there was this
you know when from the very beginning of
the computational era you know the the
numerical models the idea was so we can
do we can run numerical models ahead of
time and then that can produce the
forecast that's much more accurate than
just the ballpark numbers that you can
get from the earthquakes and that was
done this is this enemy it shows the
animation of the model animation of
fairly crude actual model of the 2004
Sumatra tsunami that's the one that
skill most almost you know nobody knows
exactly when but over two hundred
thousand people the it was it was
probably the first first model that was
done it's sort of in real time and I say
sort of because it was when this model
was complete the wave was actually
hitting the Africa here it was
devastating all over the Indian Ocean it
was about eight hours into the event and
it was claiming the last victim right
there in the South in South Africa so it
wasn't by any way by any means a
real-time forecast but what will happen
after that was that the demand for this
data for this very crude model its which
was fairly crude you know
resolution with very ballpark estimates
of numbers around the world the demand
for this data was huge the reason was
that it was pretty it was the only sort
of a measurement based data that's
available from especially from ground
zero for many hours days and weeks
actually
so that's additional interesting value
of the of the forecast it's not you know
it's you the forecast doesn't end when
you the it doesn't have to be you know
producing the numbers before the wave
hit the coast lines it's actually
extends further out you know for all the
search-and-rescue operations it's that
example showed that the the the value of
the model forecast is amazingly large
and we didn't even know how accurate
this model was this was done this model
model was based just on one data point
with there was the tie gauge like next
the Australian tide gauge about here and
Cocos Island and that was the only data
set that was used to constrain the model
because the model you know I'm the model
in myself and that's the model that I've
done i I know the model can do whatever
you want you know it's just me whenever
you put in you you know you can get
whatever output you want so constraining
it by data is it's the key for the
forecast as far as I can see and the
problem with tsunami is that the
forecast time is so short and again this
this was this event was so huge that
even days you know after eight hours it
was still the wave was propagating and
we were able to not yet you know social
media is definitely a huge resource that
hasn't been tapped into its and I heard
this you know the the yesterday the
there was presentation about the the
traffic flow modeling where the main
data set is now the cell phones that
that everybody has now and then cell
phones has a lot of
actually gauges that can be used but no
that's not this not done I'll explain
sorry they just probably was explaining
if I'm interesting I spoke to the people
at Google who do emergency response
there's a whole philanthropic part of it
and one of the things they look for is
lack yeah social media to see where
areas have been devastated as Newey's
that's right we do it right right yeah
we're definitely entering there of huge
amount of data and we still don't know
how to tap to you know to all of it yet
again and and that was the really the
beginning of the idea that the forecast
can be done and it's very useful and
it's not just for saving life of people
immediately near this near the source
but but for much wider news actually so
just to give you a brief example you
know a brief sort of X course of off of
the model developing how has it been
developed into the actual operational
forecast that we have right now in this
sort of the state-of-the-art animation
of the model that was done in 1975 the
shallow water wave equations it's that
that's what we would could do you know
in 1975 the in 1999 I've done the
animation that looks much better but
it's use the same equations pretty much
it's it it's a high resolution it looks
very realistic to you know because you
can do the much more realistic than in
1975 but basically it's the same the
same equations same model you know more
resolution more computer power we still
could not do forecast in 19 in the 90 it
was the it was a huge problem you know
part of it was that the computers were
still too much slower than now but but
the other part was actually when we sat
down with the community and looked into
the problem they there was lack of data
we didn't know how accurate this model
was because of the lack of the
observation data and there was no data
to constrain the model again so that's
that's the key so that's that's what the
community would and community centenary
communities fairly small community
before this 2004 which really expanded
the field
was maybe fifty or hundred people that
everybody knew each other it's the club
they did a small Club of very good
people by anyway so we put together a
program to to actually to get this data
that we need at least to see how the
models how accurate this models work
because the model if shallow water wave
equation is fairly kouddous crude
simplification of the navier-stokes
equation there is a lot of assumptions
there and and they seem to fit into the
tsunami tsunami physics but how well we
don't know because unless you measure it
with the realistic data you don't know
and that's that's what we did there was
a team formed a sort of informal team
that went to this this timeline I just
put it in the timeline and the red dots
of its analysis that's happened every
Sudan it pretty much was surveyed by the
team of scientists to get the actual
measurement data because unless you do
you go there and actually measure like
like this with sticks and then now with
the laser range range finders now the
data is lost
it's very perishable you know in a
couple of weeks it's going to be cleaned
up and the only thing that you will have
left unless you have the instrumental
Tagish which are not very very prolific
you know that you when you look at the
Mac it looks like they're map it looks
like there are many of them but whenever
tsunami happens there is no data there
it's just the Murphy's long so you have
to go there and and and and measure the
actual you know what we called run up
the vertical elevation of tsunami at one
land and that's something that you or
any information you can get that's the
the sort of the most quantitative
information that you can get out of that
unless you do that you get only the
eyewitness reports that's pretty much
like saying that there was a wave as
high as the sky that came and and washed
everything out so it's not not very
quantitative you can use it for
for all those for comparing with the
models at the same time there was the
the the there was a very concerted
effort in Noah by the way to come up
with the instrumental real-time
instrumental data for tsunamis there was
this deep ocean detector that was
developed over the years it was a huge
engineering effort that is sitting in
the middle of the ocean and sending data
on the satellite and measures
specifically - not very accurate it's
because it's a separate talk probably to
say all the you need to describe all the
engineering problems that we have to be
solved but it's a it's it's a detector
that's sitting at the bottom of the
oceans of the ocean measuring pressure
sending data to the buoy acoustically
because you know the Y is just too long
- you know for the buoy to hold and then
it sends it to satellites a fairly
complex system just to measure the
tsunami data the reason it's in the
bottom is that we want to filter out all
the all the mid waves we want only very
long waves which tsunamis and that can
be done if you see Lincoln Day and the
bottom of the ocean that's the pressure
will be will be felt only from these
waves from these big waves and we can
measure this the detection this the the
this instrument can measure tsunamis
about this high centimeter high that's a
key because the tsunami and the depot in
the deep ocean is very small so you need
to get a very high resolution that you
can measure very small waves to them to
propagate them to the coastline that can
be diversity so this two things sort of
came together and and we were about to
do the prototype things when when this
big tsunami in 2004 happened and that's
beats things up very much you know
there's a lot of things happened there
including the act of Congress that that
that established actually by law that
NOAA has to provide forecasts using the
data and the models and that was then
very intensive effort to develop this
forecast and in 2013 the it was actually
implemented as the capability and that's
the capability that's it's it sounds
it's actually a fairly complex system
but that's the simplest wicked yeah we
could come up with to do this real-time
forecasting empathy the problem there is
that it has to be done in a very short
amount of time short amount of time
means that the for any turn on tsunamis
happening along the know during a file
is if we take the Pacific for example
and we're taking we're talking about the
seismic generated tsunamis first that's
it's not all of the tsunamis but about
that that's about 80% of the problem 75%
of the problem there are there are the
mechanisms that are much more difficult
to actually to do the forecast for a
glance like tsunamis volcanoes in this
krookodile asteroids by the way I'll
mention that a little bit
there's meteor tsunamis the different
meteorological sources but they are all
this 20% of the problem you know that's
this this 8020 rule that you have eighty
percent of budget we usually spend to
still 20 percent of the problem so it
looks like we've done the 80 percent of
the problem but now the hard part it's
left so the the system began since the
forecast is you know you run models
ahead of time that's the forecast but
models have to be constrained by data so
it's based on data and that's the dart
is deep ocean assessment and reporting
for tsunamis these triangles the old
triangles that was a huge effort of this
during the five years to develop and
implement and actually deploy this
system of course the oceans it's it's
it's all over the place and nice thing
about it is this international community
actually picked up the you know a big
part of the problem is third third of
the array is now supported by the
international partners which is fairly
unprecedented actually it's us
technology bought by by other countries
and being used together now all the data
is is is streamed in real time for
everybody to you to be to use you have
to invert this data to do for the for
the modeling to it for the you know or
put this data into the model so the
model of simulation is not a trivial
part and mostly because it's again it's
such a short time well began the short
time means that the the closest
coastline is going to be hit by any
tsunamis
probably about twenty to twenty to
thirty minutes so that's the time
constraint that you're working against
and and and I'll tell a little bit more
about it but but the bottom line is well
some some coast lines with some coast
lines will will have twenty-four hours
for example if the tsunamis in Japan the
Chile or the other way around
Chile will receive the wave some was
today after and then it can be very
large waves you know the the United
sixty tsunami killed two hundred people
in Japan and Japan tsunami didn't kill
any people there but there was
substantial damage in Chile but but the
this is more severe impact is near the
source and that's thirty minutes an hour
well I'll show you what what what
exactly that is so that's why the data
ingestion should be very fast and the
way to do that we actually pre computed
well it since it's modeling for cat
wealthy inversion problem the way we did
it we pre compute it pretty much some
something similar to greens functions
that we can then combine without
recomputing all this all the solutions
over and over again so we can fit the
measurement data with observation the
the measurement data with models very
fast without computing a bunch of of
simulations so that's the data ingestion
and then you actually produce the
forecast you take this fairly fairly low
resolution models that that that we used
to reproduce the debated deep ocean and
then zoom into the the coastline and
when the tsunami approaches the
coastline the scale of the problem
changes quite a bit you know the length
of the wave changes so much the relative
magnitude and the the amplitude that's
why the amplitude increase just by the
conservation of the management mass and
you have to use much higher resolution
models which you can't use uniformly
throughout the ocean so we zoom in with
the nested grid type of approach so
that's that's the system anyway that has
to be all to all work together and you
know ideally in in seconds which we're
not there yet but that's that's what you
have to do
to run higher resolution models later to
help with search and rescue and things
like that to hone in on things or is
that yeah well this this forecast model
def definitely it's we we provide data
it's now available to everybody although
it's a it's it's it's a very thorny
question to because the say in real-time
the message should be very actionable
and and and clean the more linked
results usually are not that message so
you have to really distilled it into
something the action of the result of
the main goal is to save people lives
right so the people can evacuate if you
put a lot of you know scientific
graphics into the message that that may
actually be counterproductive so the the
discussion now is how much of the
information has to be put you know has
to be make public further should rescue
that's that's a no question because
there is some time there but but the in
terms of the actual one you can forecast
how much of the data that we produce
should be put into warning it's it's not
a trivial question in fact and and and
there is a lot of social studies done
you know how exactly these messages
should look like and what confirm a
Shinto you put in there so here I'll
show you a lot of information but we and
we have a wealth of information but most
of this information is now sitting in
the tsunami warning centers for them to
make a decision how to produce the
message that so yeah in general so
that's you know your measured tsunami
you us you you ingest the data you you
do the the data inversion for the models
and then you produce the forecast the
forecast is actually that which it's
it's great to know how the tsunami so
that's actually the the measurement of
tsunami in deep ocean you know that's
that's the buoy that's the surface buoy
Patrick sure it's just a transmission
device but but it transmits this data
the black is
actually it's for this Japan tsunami the
closest buoy for the Japan or source
this is the record this is almost 2
meter high amplitudes which is huge in
its it doesn't sound like much if you
are if you go to the ocean and you know
2 meter wave is nothing really you know
unusual in the in the open ocean for
tsunami amplitude this is huge this is
catastrophic genomica you know probably
you can in fact when we saw that data
first we were teaching actually we were
teaching the modeling course in in in
any in Tanzania in Africa after the
Indian Ocean event capacity-building
efforts and this data was already
available online the estimates of the
earthquake was very low that's another
problem that's why the earthquake is a
bad proxy for tsunami impact because
there's a lot of problem with with
assessing the magnitude first and then
the magnitude of the earthquakes does
not easily correspond to the poor power
tsunami and we saw this 2 meter wave
coming up in real time there was there
was really the epiphany moment they've
said that this is this is a huge tsunami
propagating so so that's the and usually
we have one or two records for that so
the problem there is that you have very
little data to constrain your models so
you have to put a lot of assumptions
into the modeling to get something
meaningful out of this very little data
you know 2 points with well is a lot of
there's a time series of course but but
this still it's very little data to
constrain it we do two to model without
any constraints so you put a lot of
constraints and constraints is really
just the historical data sets of all the
sources that have happened before
task 7 satellite SAR - can you see it
say with SI satellites sorry a bit in
fact I may go back here you mentioned
that this is actually the data the only
data for that that we did the open ocean
data for the Indian Ocean tsunami was
from satellite but it was the first and
pretty much the only data set that we
from satellite that we saw it tsunami
yet the track as the track is the
orbitty is this a Jason there there
several satellites actually the the
altimeter satellites flew through the
black is the data from the satellites
and you can see how noisy this is this
is the cyclone for example so that you
have to do a lot of data massaging
before you can see actual tsunami signal
there and and there was there was weeks
of data analysis that that we could then
use that and then put the blue is this
de modeling the model this dis model and
it compares pretty well but that was
definitely not a real time effort it was
it was research effort and that's that's
the the the best example of satellite
altimetry well there there is a new
generation of altimetry satellites that
flying now which I think have a better
resolution but the noise is not going to
go away there's a lot of noise in this
data and then it was just fortuitous
that the satellite flew over this area
about two hours into the event so they
could catch tsunami well the amplitude
was still fairly large it was about
sixty centimeters by the way here in
Japan it was about the same time after
they sorted this source it will actually
no it was closer to the source it was
two meters almost so but by the bed time
there was no satellite at that
particular moment so then Japan tsunami
actually the
there were some papers that looked at
the satellite data but they were not as
clear as that it's a difficult problem
to see the from satellite because it's
difficult data to see from satellite so
like they stole Timmy tree is that's
meteorological yes exactly exactly and
and while to put up satellite
specifically for tsunami purpose that
that hasn't this has been very popular
yet it's an expensive proposition the
whole the whole tsunami program is about
twenty five million per year so it's not
it's not a big you know budget item
there's if we can use some satellite
platforms to get this data of the great
and there are some some ideas States for
example GPS has interesting capability
they they were able to be to see the
disturbance in ionosphere that the
tsunami creates could actually be seen
on the on the GPS signal and that there
have been some data some some papers
they're looking at that but it's mostly
this data for what I've seen so far was
mostly quantitative they could actually
see propagating tsunamis in terms of the
amplitudes and quantitative numbers it
was it was very sudden
just fast-forward again a little bit so
that's the again so we do all this you
know the modeling of the of the of the
open ocean propagation and it's it's
great to know that it compares well but
the actual forecast is is the impact to
the coastline unless you get this I mean
this is this is just was for scientists
to look at the beautiful you know
comparison of the lines and just to show
you what exactly we want to model I'll
just show this this this is a fantastic
images you know the in Japan its Japan
2011 tsunami they called 311 in March 11
2011 the eight days they streamed the
event real-time because they had this
you know in Japan the the broadcast
companies actually had agreement that
they you know they were having you know
helicopters ready in case of things or
something like that so so they
broadcasted life and you could see that
that's the inundation the tsunami
inundation that will model we have to
model with our without forecasts say for
example this is you know supercritical
flow that's how it looks like in Saddam
it's very difficult tomorrow by the way
it's um doesn't look like much in here
but you can see that the the flow is
actually it's far from you know nice and
clean you know hydrodynamic flow it's
definitely a probably it's much more
complex because of the all the debris
and you see the color of the I don't
know if you saw the color the water is
black it's completely black it's not
it's and it came from the ocean so just
to give you perspective the scale of the
event you see the fires interestingly
it's very often associated with tsunamis
because when it picks up the breeze you
know if there's some some flammables
there and some electricity then the fire
starts and it carries it through to two
other locations so 5sy often
accompanying tsunamis and the power of
course you can see that you that's that
shows that nothing can withstand this
this huge tsunami and it's definitely
nothing like this nice purely wave that
you see often in the pictures of
tsunamis it's it's really a something
something really dirty and powerful that
both doors everything away in front of
it
yes that's what we want to model and the
Japan was definitely not a wake-up call
Japan is the the most vulnerable you
know country in terms of its tsunami
hazard and and this it's definitely the
most prepared and it still there is a
lot of problems that this you know
16,000 people died there and and it's
not the most populated coastline that's
that's this tsunami hit it was huge
tsunami definitely the forecast was
imminent and it's it's it's forecasted
in real time the problem is that the
forecast is much underestimated then
again because of the initial
underestimate of the earthquake the the
assessment of the amplitudes were very
underestimated that probably caused some
additional casualties there because some
people did not evacuate where it should
have been evacuated it's interesting
interesting reaction from the from the
operational warning community is that
the GMA the Japan Meteorological Agency
that that's responsible for the warning
they say we're not going to be issuing
amplitude forecasts anymore because it's
misleading its typical bureaucratic
solution to the problem you know we're
just not gonna gonna do that so that we
don't get blamed for the food
reliability and that's I mean it's it's
sounds cynical but it's actually you
know the wrong forecast kills people too
so unless you absolutely show that you
can do it accurately it may become
counterproductive to do that so it's
it's again it's complex problem because
it's so much compressed in time
the buoys that you talked about of
course there are only valuable due to
their relative distance to the epicenter
versus the coastlines distance to the
epicenter
are there enough to help Japan well okay
I'll hold this question a little bit its
difficulty I'll show you some
illustrations of that you know because
you know the short answer is known but
but it's the long answer is much more
complex the the traditional data that
went into the forecast and warning is
you know the because low tide gauges and
that didn't work well for in case of big
tsunami because they just flatlined here
these are either just destroyed
they've plane and destroyed so that
gives the coastline the coastline is hit
the worst with tsunamis so they you know
the data you know some data exists but
only far away from the source and takes
time and it's it's much more
and widget so it's more difficult to use
because of the signal-to-noise ratio
engineering design the engineering
fortification in Japan has invested
quite a bit into the mitigation by just
engineering means in fact right now that
the the most of the coastline of Japan
is just surrounded by walls which
specifically built to for tsunami
protection didn't work in this case
because they were under designed again
and and and the design is definitely
modeling effort also that that's that
you have to estimate you know how high
and how how bad the potential impact is
going to be and it was underestimated
this is a very sophisticated tsunami
wall that's supposed to automatically
goes down because it you know it what's
the river it protects the river so it
goes down only when tsunami warning
issues and it's completely destroyed it
cost probably you know half a billion
dollars just just this piece it's a very
expensive ways of doing the mitigation
and and it doesn't always work obviously
but the in terms of the forecast and
warning that's the main problem that the
Germany the Japan has faced what you see
here is the blue the dark blue is the
area that was officially designed as
evacuation areas for the tsunami so it's
supposed to be worst-case scenario
modeling assessment of what can happen
in in case of the tsunami flooding and
the the the pink is what actually
happened so that's that's where the
forecast is really needs to be you know
very accurate because people evacuated
here only to be you know killed by
tsunami and there was a lot of
evacuation areas and and it it's it's
repeated in in many different different
places so that's the real goal of
forecasts so this is should be flipped
flipped around the forecast should
definitely be conservative it it can
never happen this way
and to do that is is again it's
difficult because the forecast speed you
want to make it in time this is picture
that I like in from from the Indian
Ocean tsunami from from actually from
from Thailand and that's that's about
one hour after the event so there was no
one against Indian in the Indian Ocean
whatsoever there was no genomic when he
capability there so it was the the
earthquake happened almost hour and a
half before that pictured but no one Inc
no no nobody felt it tsunami there's a
lot of tourists and there's definitely
you know that's actually the warning
came to them as the visual realization
of the big tsunami coming up very late
they actually were saved all of these
guys has Saudi they actually escaped the
way there was an interview showing all
of them but but definitely you know if
forecast speed is important you want to
do it as soon as possible so the people
can evacuate and people can evacuate
actually that's that's it it's a doable
task because you don't you know you only
have to evacuate immediate coastline so
it's it's if people know what to do when
to do in and how to do that that's
that's possible but the it has to be
done fast and accuracy of course is is
show it is also has to be in if you if
it's an accurate forecast it's not only
useless it can be dangerous it can be
cured these two don't work well together
you know you can do you can do it fast
but it's probably not gonna do a cure it
be very accurate and you can do it very
accurate but it's going to be very late
most probably so you have to come back
come up with a compromise solution that
that's still a problem that we're still
facing and just showing you what what
has been done so far and the again
that's the forecast sequence you assess
it with with the actual tsunami
measurement data that's important to get
the accuracy down so that's what we
found if you if you you
constrain your models by actual tsunami
measurement data the accuracy goes by
the order of magnitude higher so you
have much much better accuracy still may
not be enough everywhere but that's why
you know you have to actually measure
tsunami then you can get a good forecast
do the assessment of a source and then
do propagation and then the actual
forecast is is that the impact of the
coastline it would with what it shows is
this picture is the Kahului Hawaii for
the Japan tsunami that's the forecast
actually it's the first sort of flooding
forecast that that has ever been done
showing the the flooding of Kahului and
Cucuy was Hawaii was evacuated but there
was you know in some sense an easy task
because it's about six to seven hours
before the wave hit after the earthquake
and that state all the capability was
already implemented at that time so if
it didn't work with in this case it we
should probably thrown everything away
and went to jail for spending the money
but but it worked well for for the for
the far field and do so again the the
models it's this shows the animation how
this modeling you know it's just
animation of the models the model
actually run much faster than that than
even that animation because we we
optimized the model to run as fast as
possible but it zooms into into this
Kauai chain then it's like every single
hour and then it Sea Island and then the
sort of the harbor level about 10 10
meter to 30 meter great resolution very
high resolution up to building size
resolution that that gets you the
estimate of flooding fairly well that's
what we see at least so that's and
that's then you can compare it you know
after the facts you can compare and
that's important to get to make sure
that you are actually you're getting
some forecasted skills because if you if
you don't have the metric that to
compare your you know forecast results
with observations then you don't know
how well you're doing you
how well you're improving and and what
to improve so the tide gauges provide
you know important independent data the
problem with that is we still don't know
what's the good metric you know how to
tell how to estimate how would we we've
done you know so visually it it's the
the comparison often you know appears
well but in some cases it can be as
underestimated but then can be very
small waves so the the where the noise
to to signal ratio is very bad is it a
bad comparison is it a bad forecast or
is that the metric is that we designed
is we right now we're using very
simplified one just compare the maximum
computed wave with the maximum measured
wave and it showed that it may not be
the good metric to you to use because
it's it you know the big waves and small
waves they they have the same weight and
we're not sure if that's that should be
the case because the the forecast skills
you know sort of it almost favors the
small amplitude tsunamis which are which
are almost impossible to get right so
you don't really know how well your
forecast dance and so that that has been
done for computed for not just for
Hawaii but for it was almost 50/50 like
most populated populated coastline
communities around the United States
that's what we've done this
high-resolution modeling for and and and
all you know and in the comparison with
with the gauges starts all over the
Pacific that shows that the deep ocean
comparison the red is the model the
deliveries the the measurement again
this tsunami was fairly well
instrumented and for the far field we've
done you know fairly well so that shows
it's sorry it's small small graphics
it's you know it's done for the purpose
so you don't see how well we've done but
with but I put the numbers here the it's
especially for larger waves the the
accuracy which again is a very
simplified metric of just ratio between
and and simulated is about you know it's
about 880 percent for the smaller ones
about seventy percent so 70 percent a we
still have a 30 percent error is it is
it a big error or small error I don't
know this well what would would that
seem to indicate that it if it's a
flooding event which seems to be which
which is actually the trigger for the
evacuation so and that's what we will be
trying at least to get right so the
flooding is is forecasted very robustly
with this error so if it's a it's a big
flooding event the it's it's it's gonna
be triggered it will be it's gonna it's
gonna show that and it's going to show
the flooding forecast
so that there was done for the for this
event but we actually have done it for
for many other events too so they wish
we starting to get the forecasts cues
and these numbers that I showed it sort
of hold for for other events most of
them are smaller but the you know the
last sort of big one was in Chile here
at 2015 what they actually the very last
tsunami was actually in January the end
of January in Alaska it was a small
tsunami but it was a big scare because
the earthquake was fairly large but it
was very unusual it was not on the
typical sort of what would we call
subduction zone she was not a typical
thrust event that creates big tsunamis
it was in a intraplate inside the plate
so it was big earthquake but but not
very big tsunamis but it was detected
all over the Pacific it was kind of
interesting event that is good you know
tsunami do we like this tonight tsunamis
that don't create damage but provide a
lot of data because it it gives us
opportunity to you know to look at the
models and to see to improve our
forecast skills at what we call it the
term from the from the weather service
actually and it's you know we'll it was
in Chile we actually we don't have high
resolution models for Chile for the
real-time although we now we're working
with Chilean government to produce some
of those but but for the models in the
in the in in us that we've done pretty
well it and it was based on the on the
two darts that and we've done some
statistics on the on the model that
still holds with so we bought you know
an average but still 30% error but for
large amplitudes we actually do better
so which is which is great because
that's what we want so if we if we have
large tsunami propagating we our
forecast is actually doing pretty well
now and that's some pictures from they
from the ground zero I'll just zoom zoom
through here the biggest problem you
know the challenge that that we now face
is the challenge of the
what we call near field forecast because
this that's what the timing and the
amplitudes are severe you know both you
know it's it's a very short time and
it's again Japan tsunami they have a lot
of extra instruments many of them were
not real time but we get a lot of data
and we could we could use that to do
fairly higher it's after the fact we've
done in collaboration with with Japan
colleagues we've done again the problem
one of the issues that we face there
since our main goal is to actually the
colors are there the forecast is
flooding you know this is the coastline
and that's what was flooded and the the
white line is the measured inundation
extent so done pretty well I mean it it
looks like we've we've we can compute
and that was actually the forecast they
had based on this real-time observations
so it the actual computations were done
after the fact but it was done as if it
was done in real time how good is it
numerically it's it's it's well sort of
quantitatively we still don't know one
metric for the for the flooding you know
for the actual flooding we thought of
just the the area of flooding and and
that's actually they've turned out to be
but about the same the same error about
70% you know if you compare the flooded
area of forecast and and the
measurements
but but that's a difficult metric to get
because you have to emit this is this
this was a huge can serve a campaign to
get all this all this cost lines it's
very difficult I know I've been to the
surveys you have to walk the line that's
a huge amount of survey Inc that needs
to be done so that's that's another
thing since this this is the actual goal
of the forecast to produce the flooding
extent and how accurate we can do that
we don't know the relevance of the local
problem of course is the Cascadia
subduction zone so this is you know
which sort of we have this this
comparison of this tonight Japan tsunami
it's a 2011 and this one of the
projections of the future 9.1 Cascadia
subduction zone event which is going to
be largely if the whole subduction zone
ruptures which is what you know some of
the scenario would most scenarios shows
that not most now there are some some
some there are papers showing that it
actually can be only from the part of
the seductions on can rupture also so we
don't know that but the whole rupture is
also feasible and this is comparison of
the sort of maximum amplitude that you
can expect the red is actually measured
so Roenick fights in the longer the
japan coast line and the the model the
the grey dots the models along the
coastline of you know Washington Oregon
and in Northern California
these are higher because because of the
geometry pretty much and the exposure is
about this is actually very similar but
remember Japan is the most educated
population in terms of the tsunami
threat and tsunami exercises so well it
was actually less than they were at
16,000 there was the initial estimate so
about 20,000 it's think it's just over
16,000 they was killed
what's going to happen here we we don't
know there's a lot of efforts going on
on the sort of underground level also
that the people there are the education
with the campaign's they're the the
evacuation drills going on but how well
the population is prepared we don't know
and and a lot of population is sexually
transmitted because there's all of
tourists there and that's different you
know different paradigm you can teach
the local population what to do but then
the tourists so that's it's definitely
like the inlets and the rivers model
yeah well this is the course model but
yeah let me show this we can zoom in to
thee so this is the Long Beach Peninsula
which is a big problem in Washington
instead of Washington this is Columbia
River and and the problem is that that
it's pretty much over washed by the
tsunami which means that there is no way
to evacuate people there and that's a
very popular tourist destination
actually in Washington so that's and
that we can model that you know and but
it's when we when we work there is a lot
of this what's called national tsunami
hazard mitigation program it's a group
of interagency intergovernmental group
that gets together and and decide what
to do of with with the warnings for
example like like that or with the
threat assessments like that and you
know sort of discussions of how to deal
with the long beach problem and and we
you know the first step is to assess the
hazard and we do the simulations and
give it to emergency managers and they
just say what what do you want us to do
with this
for example there was happened actually
in in in Seattle there's a see I'm from
Seattle so I best in CLO so this we
worked with the city of Seattle to
assess the has that there is this what's
called Seattle fault that goes right
through downtown Seattle and actually
crosses the Elliott Bay I don't have
these pictures here and it's known to
produce a tsunami about 900 years ago
and this is it it's there and we know
that it happened because there was a
very good evidence of the displacement
there we know it was happened once we
don't know if it's gonna happen again or
if it ever happened before so that so we
but we did this worst case scenario as
we designed and that shows fairly
devastating impact on the cost on the on
the coastline of off of Seattle you know
Seattle coastline and we showed it to
Cheryl the emergency managers they said
okay thank you very much for your water
jacket and put it somewhere in the Shelf
because there's not my with the the the
travel time there was two minutes so two
minutes in two minutes they'd be 10
meter waves hitting the the very
touristy Seattle coastline don't know
how to manage this kind of threat
so that's it there is an issue there you
know this we can do this the hazard
assessment but then how to mitigate this
concept is a different problem so anyway
just briefly maybe I saw it yeah
probably at the end of my talk just to
to show you what what exactly you know
what's the state of the art right now
and what are the challenges in terms of
the producing the forecasts they'll just
put it in it you know this forecast in
the sort of the timeline cycle here and
it's a cycle because the cycle goes the
goes around with more data that's come
it comes in so it again this is the
forecast that's what we want to do the
rest are just steps to get to that to
the impact of the you know of the of the
potential tsunami flooding because
that's the bulk of the tsunami impacts
any community it all starts with the
with the earthquakes well we again we
talk about the earthquakes only now now
it cuz 70% of the problem it takes about
you know three to 15 minutes to just
assess to just know that the earthquake
happened and how big this earthquake is
and three minutes is pushing it three
minutes that's when Japan first
estimates came out and it was hugely
underestimated so that may be problem so
we know that that initial estimate is
going to be very problematic very
uncertain but you can still use that
because that's the data that you have
and you can run your you know you can do
the the inversion well this in this case
it's gonna be very simple just just
scale up our our sources with with the
magnitude of the earthquake and and
actually run the the coastline you know
the high resolution models you know it
takes some time and and and even before
you get the actual measurement of
tsunami because it's the key to get the
actual forecast and you already over 30
minute time line and and you do some
forecast you can do some forecasts but
it's probably gonna be garbage in 50 now
50 percent of the time very inaccurate
not garbage no I don't don't want to say
it's garbage but it's gonna be very
inaccurate and then you repeat this
cycle but that takes more time you can
get this forecast
more and more accurate it would be great
if we know where the earthquake is gonna
happen you know we're still waiting for
there for the seismic community to give
us this promise that they can predict
earthquakes you know at least the
location you know some ballpark
magnitude whatever it'll be great then
we can do we can still use the same
cycle of you know of the forecast and
provide the forecast beforehand and be
ready to you know for all the and then
for the for the updates
that's probably unrealistic future from
what I hear from the from our seismic
colleagues we shouldn't expect any any
earthquake you know short-term
earthquake prediction anytime soon so we
still stuck with this three to 15
minutes and that's the 15 minutes is
just you big earthquake stages the
shaking continued the rupture continues
for almost 10 minutes for example they
the the Indian Ocean tsunami or
disruption for about 10 minutes thousand
kilometers long fault
so it's until it's in its complete the
rupture is complete you can't really get
assessment of the earlier or the source
but so if we stuck with that initial
assessment there we can do the modeling
now very fast the talks that I heard
yesterday they were great it's it's the
you know the computer the Moore's law is
sort of slowing down but it's still
working great you know we still have
they were just just waiting 10 years
doing nothing without more link we got
two orders of magnitude faster models
fantastic if a GPU is just magic you
know it just hundred hundred times
faster models so now what we and we
optimized our models already to run in
like 10 minutes now we can do it in
seconds so it's you know to do the
computations I mean we can always use
all the computer capacity what you would
get its but we can optimize it to get
very fast modeling and if you put if you
have the data in sort of in 10 minutes
then you can get the forecast to less
than 15 minutes the key of course so the
computation is at least right now
doesn't seem to be the bottleneck of
this process is the matter
because that you know the key is the
tsunami measurement and the problem with
this is yeah you could put you can put
that's coming back to your question you
can put detectors very close to
potential sources we actually know where
the potential sources are they around
this you know big subduction zones big
faults yeah problem there is that when
the earthquake happens it creates huge
shaking and that the tsunami if you
could that's an example of actually yeah
there's some some of the cable system
they were installed in Japan you see
this this black light it's actually it's
it's noise its seismic noise that's
recorded on the gauges and the deep
ocean gauges and you can see tsunami on
did there's tsunami embedded internet so
there's additional problem that there's
this noise in order for us it's noise
for seismic community it's it's data so
it's it's it's classically you know
somebody's noise is somebody else's PhD
it's it's exactly what it is but but it
creates the problem for us the you know
what tsunami forecast capabilities but
it's solvable problem but but you know
you can filter it out because the
frequency is much higher but to filter
it efficiently you have to have very
high frequency data stream and that's
another problem you know there's our the
buoys are you know they're the
independent you know the the
self-contained systems they run on
batteries and if you have very high
frequency of the data stream then the
batteries just run flat very pretty soon
a lot of engineering problems but but
they you know the engineers are solving
those so the you can actually put this
the next generation buoy that now is
being deployed that has very high
frequency can send data real-time and
you can put them very close to the
source but but then to resolve this
source you have to have much more than
so this is the existing dartboards and
this is the analysis it is some one of
the proposals it went you know so it's a
it's order of magnitude more data and
this buoys are not you know they did not
cheap they there it you know the the and
but the biggest cost is actually the
ship time to deploy them because the the
the buoys themself is probably three
hundred thousand but then to deploy them
it gets them almost up to a million per
system where the alternatives I mean
there are some alternatives think the
cable system was big in Japan after the
after the well it was before Japan
tsunami but after the event there was
huge efforts to this to deploy this
massive cable system with the same
detection the same detection that we use
in our you know the yeah good question
the the they actually designed to last
what's the batteries can last for four
years so they're they optimized you know
that and the big and the reason is that
you know the the actual detector is
sitting at the bottom and the bottom is
very stable environment it's very cold
continuous you know temperature very
good for batteries so they can last
forever the problem is the the the buoy
the the surface unit that has a lot of
the you know the marine environment is
very tough environment it's you know
arguably it's tougher than than space
actually because it's you know the salt
Carosa the material the waves it's just
the you can't use for example the the
solar panels because they become opaque
in in a couple of days by salt salt just
put you know on top of that and it
becomes useless so the right now the
since its operational system they want
to make sure that they work so they
actually change it every year so there's
a ship that goes around and just and and
change them every year but the idea is
to have sort of disposable system that
you just put out there for maybe two
years because the surface booze is still
challenging
or maybe four and that that makes it
cheaper again because the ship time is
huge part of the cost well there's no
ship time here but this the cost of this
system for this massive system
I think it's pushing billion dollars
it's a hugely expensive system and and
they have a lot of I mean they still
it's they started to deploy it you know
shortly after the two thousand eleven
and there's there's a lot of issues they
did that I mean it's it's it's great
data it's cable they don't have problem
with power with time frequency but
noises huge problem because that you
know this we know the in oceanography
you know the the shallow you get the
more active the environment becomes so
that's why they put this additional you
know string that that goes beyond the
shelf and they just it's just a recent
addition and they still have problems
with that so but but but they it's
coming up online you know as in Japan
it's you know the the decision is made
that they're going to deliver and that's
fantastic that we haven't seen the data
yet we have seen some pieces of that
data but not real-time data and with
real-time is going to be a lot of
there's similar efforts in Canada and in
US and there's well they're the actual
problem actually in Japan is is here
it's it's none kind trench because
that's that's where they they were
expect they have been expecting tsunami
all along it just happened in the wrong
time in the wrong place because the the
the both the populations here you know
Tokyo base here Yokohama all the
exposure is there and and that hasn't
happened yet they still they've been
waiting for it for 50 years it happened
here but it's it hasn't materialized
here so but the system went into this
into this place there are some
components and they in the other
locations do there's some other data the
GPS turn out to be a very good source of
data for them since the tsunamis
generated by the displacement that the
the earthquake generates seismic data is
very bad date it's very difficult data
to get this sexual dispar mannan
displacement out the GPS actually
measures permanent displacement so it's
it's a better data than seismic the
problem with that is that they all on
land so it's one-sided it's skewed data
set difficult to invert to actual to get
the actual do you know displacement it's
offline and the other sources I just
mentioned sorry they briefly the meteor
tsunami is actually for the East Coast
is a bigger problem than the seismic
tsunamis because in the Atlantic they
earthquakes do happen but but not very
often and and there was the event in
2013 that created you know somebody was
was was washed out phone from the pier
so there was a lot of media coverage
there was a system there were the system
that's there's a weather system
propagating across from land to to the
ocean and we model that just assuming
there's not a lot of data there we just
assumed the deaths proxy for the
pressure field that that can create
disturbance on the ocean and that's the
disturbance actually there's an
interesting phenomenon called prodeman
resonance so if this system propagates
with a certain speed it can actually
resonate with its resonance Friesen
speed probe generated tsunamis and
that's actually it feed the data pretty
well so that's just just this crude
model we were able because they did this
was detected on our observation system
there's a dart sitting there
and some some horse wine it actually fit
fairly well we I mean we do better with
our seismic data but it was very
encouraging that is potentially the
capability that we can use put to use
this capability the data is going to be
the key because that was we just it was
really shot in the dark you know we say
okay well we'll just use that as a proxy
for the pressure field and there is no
high resolution pressure field available
for the [ __ ]
the asteroids we actually have done
since it's it's actually very similar to
the to this meaty of genomic field
because it's we decided that that the
the actual unknown in terms of the
asteroids is how big of the tsunami can
destroy it like this the one that you
showed in Chelyabinsk with a pressure
wave can generate a pressure wave that's
propagating with the speed you know
speed of sound
create any any any any tsunami the thing
is that you know the speed of sound 330
meters per second it's it's about the
same as the propagation of tsunami in
the deepest part of the ocean so the you
know tanaami actually almost hitting the
the sound barrier if it propagates in
like in mariana trench or something so
it's close in terms of this this
resonant speed so we've done and and the
reason why this is important is that you
know the big impact like like Katie or
or to maybe even Tunguska
we obviously created a big splash big
tsunami and maybe even the end of
civilization event but if you if you try
to assess the risk and we will that's
the work joint with with NASA
it's a near-earth object group there's
the one sexually hearings in
the dreams and their dams in the aims
the the way they you know it's it's
coming back to this you know to the risk
versus budget versus what what do we
want to do with with this problem is
that they they sense the risk is in in
terms of fatalities per year and and and
if you put this plot you know diameter
of the impact of the of the of the
asteroid versus fatalities you know the
big ones the the you know there is a
bump there but there's uncertainty in
the middle and then certainty is related
to the auctioning but you know 2/3 of
their of the meteorites will go into the
ocean just because it did you know the
2/3 of the earth is covered with water
and the impact of that or the the
effects of this impact is is a very
uncertain because the modeling is very
difficult actually it's extremely
difficult this the you know they're
Hydra models that you know this is you
know what is it few microseconds of the
or maybe a few seconds no 10-second 100
second my god so that's that's you know
stretching it to the to the limits of
the computers it's but to propagate
these waves and to see what the impact
is is pretty much impossible with the
Hydra models so we worked with them to
get this this input and to see well this
and actually impact from the from the
shockwaves and to see what it can create
and you know we've done some exercises
there was a rock ship in Seattle that
showed you know that this this model I
think it's similar to Tunguska
asteroid to put it somewhere in you know
offshore Washington why not because they
were stay where they were the workshop
is in to assess the impact and since
that was a fairly small event and and
the assumption is is completely
disintegrated is just the shockwaves
that hitting the ocean no no actual
impact there is it's not a end of
civilization event but there is some
substantial tsunami that that that
creates this this event race and it
depends very much and where exactly this
impact is
if you if you if you hit the deep ocean
you know they say Mariana Trench then
the the triggering is almost perfect
perfect actually it's an interesting
it's it's unfinished work which we sort
of we ran out of budget there but but
this was very exciting things to do so
I'll stop here Thanks
run just a little over any other quick
questions